did you write the script and then pitch
to Harvey Weinstein or did he say I want
you to write something about this or did
you say I'm thinking about something
with slavery or how did that happen with
him no I I never do a pitch kind of
thing I um the only reason you do
pitches is if you're like want to be
paid for writing your script I don't
want to be paid for writing my script I
want people to buy my scpt I want you
know we're going to make this movie when
I'm done so I want to Own It Up Up Until
the you know up until the financing is
concerned so I always write it on spec I
always just write it myself it's mine
and so then I don't have to explain it I
don't have to sell anybody on it I give
them the script they either like it or
they don't